now many parents are hoping to get their
children off the city and into the
kitchen during this period of isolation
why not good idea to do a bit of cooking
our next guest might provide you with a
little bit of inspiration and mari
McQueen is just 11 and already an
award-winning vegan chef we can talk to
him now
along with Megan Swan who joins us from
the charity chicks which helps young
people get away into into country breaks
and get out of the city good to see you
both this morning and Mari I have to
start with you why have you got so much
of a passion for cookery question
cooking is because I get to bring more
people together freak me about Halloween
your mind has it been a little bit
difficult because I've I've been looking
for some sort of cooking ingredients in
the supermarket and that mainly been
sold out so what are you using to be
able to keep the cooking going it's not
really hot but it's well look let's talk
to Megan and can I ask you about chicks
and the word that you're doing to get
people you know young people at
difficult at this time but ordinarily
out and about getting them into a
different environment yes so and just to
give some context of what we do kind of
in normal circumstances we provide
respite breaks to vulnerable children
from across the UK and like you said we
bring them to our specialist retreats
and we provide opportunities for them to
discover new passions new hobbies and
things that they're interested in to
help increase self-esteem and encourage
curiosity and adventure and ultimately
what we want to do is to provide
children with these magical moments
where they've really
achieve something that can lead them to
kind of go on to believe that and to
know that they can achieve more than
they ever thought possible which sounds
great Megan but how do you deal with
that under the under these restrictions
so with these restrictions you know
these are unprecedented time so what we
have done is we have set up through
various social media platforms for our
chicks families and chicks children and
likewise other children's and families
to access daily activities daily
challenges inspiration and we're so
lucky to have teamed up with an
incredible inspiring and person like
Amari to bring these this content and
inspiration to people in their homes so
essentially we're taking a taste of our
respite breaks to people in their homes
for them to experience it um as the in
the safest way possible which that
sounds wonderful Megan is a great job
that you're doing and it's a fantastic
work that you're doing and Mari I fancy
a little bit about myself thank you very
much indeed both for joining us here on
Sky News this morning